hello
um so um hello everybody today
i will talk to you about micrornas
in extracellular vesicles and how they
orchestrate
the biology of the tumor
microenvironment
first of all i would like to make my
disclosure so i
have no financial relationships to
disclose
the outline of today's talk will be
essentially in these four points the
first part of the lecture
will be on the classification of
extracellular vesicles
and we will talk about the physiology of
micrornas
since the topic of this talk is the role
of micrornas in extracellular vesicles
and how they shape the biology of the
tumor microenvironment
then we will talk about the classical or
traditional
mechanisms of action of micrornas and
their alternative or more
novel discoveries about how they work
and then
we will talk about the discovery of mere
sectors and i will define what i mean by
that
and what is their implication in the
biology of the tumor microenvironment
and then we will focus a little bit more
on a specific
aspect of the biology of vesicular
micrornas with reference to
the natural killer derived exosomal
micrornas and how they shape the biology
of the tme
so um the classification of
extracellular vesicles
is listed here it's not complete and
it's constantly changing so
um but it reflects essentially what we
know
as of yet regarding how we can classify
extracellular vesicles
a lot of people think that the term
exosome
is a synonym for extracellular testicles
well this is incorrect
because exosomes are just the one
subtype
of ev or extracellular vesicles
which includes a broader family of
vesicles and to be more specific
exosomes can be considered as this
some of the smallest type of vesicles
indeed as you see
in the in this slide under the size
column you see that exosomes have
a range in size between 40 and 120
nanometers
whereas the micro vesicles have a range
between 50 nanometers and one micron
and then we have apoptotic bodies that
the range between 500 nanometers and two
microns
but there are also other uh categories
of eds that have been
more recently identified one
includes smaller vesicles than exosomes
that are the ectosomes that are
between 10 and 20 nanometers and then we
have
large um oncosomes that are actually
vesicles that are bigger than the other
than the apoptotic bodies
and whose size range is between 1 micron
and 10
microns now as you can see from this
slide though
that a pure size is not good enough to
differentiate
different type of vesicles because there
are areas of overlapping if you just
look at the size of them
let's say for instance you have a
vesicles that is 100 nanometers you
wouldn't be able just
based on the size to determine or to
state
that that vesicle is an exosome or a
micro vesicle
so how can you differentiate between
these two different groups of vesicles
there are different criterias
some of them include essentially looking
at surface marker expression
in particular exosomes tend to express
tetraspanning such as t-span 29 t-span
30 um other mem other molecules such as
dsg-101
and so on micro vesicles tend to express
integrins cd4 ligand and selectings
apoptotic bodies are characterized by
the extensive amount of
phosphatidylserine because of the
flapping of the
um lipids in the membrane when
the the cell dies um
[Music]
originally it was quite difficult to
differentiate different type of evs so
at some point
the international society for
extracellular vesicles
isaf came up with
a series of guidelines that are called
the minimal requirement
for the definition of an extracellular
vesicles as an
exosome or as another type of evs among
the different listed before and i have
to say that this is a very helpful uh
tool because
it allows all scientists from different
labs to essentially start talking the
same language
and start defining their vesicles with
the proper name
based on the criteria that need to be
met in order to
define a vesicle in a certain way or
another these
guidelines are constantly updated there
has been an update
in november of 2017 from the original
publication in december 2014
and we are we have constantly so so you
are encouraged to follow the updates
that the society
provides in terms of the requirement for
the definition of the different
subcategories of evs
um just to keep going about the
physiology of these extracellular
vesicles
uh they the exosomes so that the
category that ranges between 30 40 to
120 nanometers in size and expresses
tetraspanings
are derived from the endosomal
compartment so as you can see here
they are originating through different
mechanisms
involving escort dependent and escort
independent machinery from the mvb
here at the center of the slide which
stays for multivesicular body
and then these mvbs under undergo a
maturation inside of the cytosol of the
cell and can
essentially follow two paths one is to
go
through degradation inside of lysosomes
the other one is to migrate through the
plasma membrane mainly
thanks to arab 27 members
uh that allows the migration of the late
mvv
through the plasma membrane where the
membrane of the mvp
fuses with the plasma membrane releasing
the little tiny exosomes outside of the
cell
um differently than that
you have that micro vesicles as you can
see
in the upper left part of this cartoon
seem to originate
mostly from a direct blabbing
of the plasma membrane so with the
minimum involvement
of the endosomal compartment and
machinery
this is uh at this point almost a
historic
image it was one of the first images
of extracellular vesicles
bleeding from the surface of
glioblastoma cells
in this seminal paper of
dr skog with um coming from the group of
sandra brakefield at harvard
they were able to show indeed for the
first time that there is
um the these vesicles blabbing from the
surface of cells can actually
be imaged and extracellular vesicles
really contain
a whole different types of cargo
molecules
essentially it has been shown that every
possible
macromolecule you can think of can
be part of the cargo of evs so inside of
evs you can find
uh proteins of course you can find also
i'm not sure what happened here so okay
so you can find ev
you can find proteins you can find the
messenger rnas you can find
um non-coding rnas both micrornas and
long non-coding rnas and people have
described also
dna inside of vesicles and also
as i said previously vesicles are
characterized by the different type of
molecules that define their surface
landscape briefly i would like to go
through
some seminal discoveries on the
role of extracellular vesicles in cancer
this is from the group of david lydon
and they were the first
to provide evidence that the
melanoma-derived exosomes
are able to educate bone marrow
progenitors by
transferring um the oncogenic
oncogene mat and also they were able to
show that exosomes are able to induce a
vascular leakiness at the premetastatic
niche
and so if you block it up 27a
which is one of the proteins involved in
the migration of the multivesicular body
to the plasma membrane
these decreases the exosome formation
and metastasis
and they were able to identify also
specific exosomic
melanoma signature which involves genes
such as terp2
vla4 hsp70 and that
with prognostic implications so it was
of the first paper really showing
convincingly that the protein and
oncogene can be transferred
from cancer-derived exosomes to cells
of the pre-metastatic niche priming it
to receive metastatic cells
and then another uh seminal paper here
from
um michiel patel and jakob van nerinen
they were able to show that for the
first time
in vivo that there is an effect
of exosomes on
um other cells of the tumor micro
environment so vesicles released from
the cancer cells can actually
have an effect that can be actually
documented in vivo
uh on other cells of the tumor micro
environment using a very elegant system
that combines equilox
evidence of an effect of
the content the cargo of vesicles on the
recipient cells in the tme in vivo
then a ragu kaluri's group provided the
first
evidence that surface
markers of vesicles such as gleepikan1
can be used to identify
cancer-derived exosomes particularly
beneficial in the early diagnosis of
pancreatic cancer
so providing a lot of hope of course for
patients that have this type of cancer
because
as you know and as we speak this is
still a very deadly type of cancer and
the early diagnosis represents probably
the most powerful tool we have
as of yet for the um healing and the
treatment of these disease so having
an early marker to be detected in in
circulating exosome is certainly a very
powerful tool
against this disease another important
paper again from the
group of david lydon provided the first
evidence that actually vesicles are
involved
in the tropism of metastatic cells
so in other words um cancer cells seems
to be directed
to a specific target metastatic
organ after this organ has been
primed by the vesicles by the exosome
released by these cancer cells so they
did
a series of very elegant experiments
showing that
if you have let's say um cancer a breast
cancer cell line that has
tropism for the lung and one breast
cancer cell line that has a tropism for
the brain for instance
if you prime the animal with the
exosomes derived from the cell that has
tropism from the lung and then you put
the cells that tends to go to the brain
these cells actually will go to the lung
just because there has been a priming
from the exosomes derived from a long
tropic
uh cell line so this was a very powerful
evidence that the vesicles have
an incredible central role playing
incredible center
central role in the definition of the
target organ for
the metastatic process they were able
also to identify
which genes are involved in these
traffic of the vesicles showing in
particular that specific type of
integrins expressed in the surface
of the vesicles tend to define a certain
uh tropic tropism certain organ as the
destination of the vesicle itself
and then the group of dolores divizio
and colleagues at cedar sinai
have provided a very broad and extensive
definition
of the role of large oncosomes so
they're the biggest
group of vesicles we can think of as of
yet
so the ones that range from let's say
one micron to 10 microns they were able
to show that
specifically highly metastatic prostate
cancer cells
tend to release this large oncosome
and these contributes significantly to
the metastatic process
so this was a little bit of a um
background
on some of the most relevant literature
in the field
and now i want to go a little bit more
specifically on the topic of this talk
defining the after i define the vesicles
defining the other
main character in this plot in this
story that i'm about to share with you
so micro rnas um i'm not sure
uh all of you are familiar with
micrornas that's why i provided these
apparently complicated slide but
actually it's not that complicated
if you follow me step by step that tells
you about the biogenesis and especially
the physiology and the function of micro
rnas
so starting from the um
[Music]
elliptical blue area in the upper left
side of these
uh supposed to be gigantic cell
that represents the nucleus of the cell
so just to tell you that micrornas like
every other
protein coding gene is actually is
a gene so is a piece of dna which is
transcribed
uh through to into a pre-micrornas so
primordial pri
microrna you have to pay attention to
letters here to
pri and so this primordial microrna is
then processed inside of the nucleus of
the cell
by an enzyme called drosha with the
coenzyme called the dgcr8
into a precursor micro rna so pre
microrna which is
characterized by a hairpin structure is
a helping precursor
and this pre-microrna is then
shifted from the nucleus inside of the
inside of the cytoplasm of the cell
by means of exporting 5 with a coenzyme
called rand gtp
and here the premicron am needs a
ribonuclear
nucleoprotein complex called risk which
is composed of different parts
the first one is dicer which essentially
takes away the loop of the mirror
leaving a duplex which is opened by a
helicase
and then for thermodynamic reasons one
of the two strands
of the duplex is preferred and becomes
the mature single stranded microrna
which is long about
19 to 24 nucleotides and
guided by other proteins in the risk
complex mainly
argonaut 2 in humans finds an
a complementary or almost complementary
sequence
in a target messenger rna mostly but not
exclusively as we will see in a minute
at the three prime utr end of the
transcript
as a consequence you can have um mostly
a translational repression
if there is an imperfect base pair
pairing of the microrna with the target
messenger rna
sometimes and especially in plants more
than in humans
you have a perfect match between all the
bases of the microrna
and the target messenger rna in which
case you have
an actual cleavage of both the messenger
rna
end of the microarray in 2007
a brilliant discovery by vasudevan and
colleague showed for the first time
that actually microrna can also
bind to the five prime utr of
uh a gene and as a consequence of that
you can have actually an increase the
translation so not a decrease
translation will actually increase the
expression of the proteins
here is a summary of the possible
outcome of the microarray
messenger rna interaction most
frequently you have what's happening in
the top
part of the cartoon so you have the
microrna attached to the
risk complex binding to the three prime
utr of the target messenger rna
and you can have a messenger rna
degradation especially if the
match is perfect or you can have
translational repression if the match is
imperfect or doesn't occur in all
of the 100 percent of all the bases of
the micro name matching to the three
prime utr
if you have a binding to the five prime
utr region you can have still a
translational repression
but you can have also the translational
activation i was mentioning before
microrna can also bind to the coding
sequence
and these almost invariably
results into a translational repression
and
that's pretty much all the outcome you
can have
having said that in
more recent years um different groups
have shown that
in addition to these traditional
mechanisms of action of micrornas which
is which are the ones we just analyzed
you can have also alternative mechanisms
of action which are listed here
in the left you see again one of the
first
alternative mechanism as i said is the
fact that the mirrors can actually
increase the translation of a messenger
rna into a protein
and then on the right side you have a
brilliant observation done by
um dr erin at the time she was working
in dr danilo perotti's lab
they were the first to show that a
microrna can actually
interact directly with a protein so not
with the messenger rna
in this specific work they were showing
that mere 328 by binding to
um a protein called hrnp e2
we're able to subtract or take away this
hrnp
e2 factor from its binding to a
transcription factor called cebp
alpha and normally hrnp e2 inhibits
cbp alpha but the presence of the mir
prevents this inhibition and so cebp
alpha allows the transcription
of factors that allow a granulocytic
differentiation
now in leukemias you have a dow
regulation of mere 328.
therefore hrnpe2 is free to bind and
inhibit cavp alpha so there is a block
internal acidic differentiation which is
key to the um
leukemic process the hemogenic process
but the point here that i'm trying to
highlight is the fact that this paper is
the first one
showing a completely different mechanism
of action for micrornas as
able to interact with
a protein instead of a messenger rna
so this is very important this
observation that micrornas can bind to
protein is very important for the story
i'm about to share
the other background to the story is
this
table which is just a very um
oversimplification of the uh of the
situation but it gives you
an idea where we are going from here
so at some point in the microrna history
uh people started looking at the
expression of micrornas in the blood
first and then essentially they started
looking all possible biological fluids
and the first uh paper
that actually looked at micrornas from
this perspective is actually the second
one listed here
so to give the right credit to the right
people so
by mitchell at all they showed that in
prostate cancer patients you have high
level
of circulating in the blood mere 141
compared to healthy men the the other
counterpart
so why is this a paper important and the
other ones listed here because these
were the first
um papers showing for the first time
that micrornas can be
can be effectively used as cancer
biomarkers because they can be
found in a biological fluids and they
can actually
predict if a patient has cancer or not
and in those years actually in 2007
at all of the group of jan lotron
provided a very at the very first
evidence
that micrornas can be shuttled
functionally from one cell to another
inside of extracellular vesicles
and when i mean what i mean by
functionally i mean that
um cell number one here you see mast
cell number one
releases micrornas inside of
extracellular vesicles
and if you take the supernatant not the
cell but just the supernatant
from these cell culture mast cell number
one and you put it on the top
of mass cell number two which is in a
completely different flask and so has
never been
in any contact with mast cell number one
except for the fact that you put the
supernatant derived from number one
into number two you have the these
micrornas contained in the vesicles
released by mast cell number one
enter into my mast cell number two
and they started targeting messenger
rnas in this
uh recipient cell it was a very
fundamental observation
that essentially was telling us that
microrna can shuttle from one cell to
another
inside of it so now putting
these three pieces of evidence i just
provided in the previous
three slides together so the fact that
micrornas can bind to proteins
the fact that they can be found
circulating and the fact that they can
be transferred from one cell to another
prompted me and my group to
think of micrornas in a completely
different
setting not only as
regulators of gene expression by
modulating the translation
rate of messenger rna but actually as
hormones because if you think of
hormones the definition of a hormone is
a molecule
which is secreted by one cell which is
part of a gland
goes into circulation and does something
on an
effector cell so at the distance by
binding
mostly through a to a protein receptor
so it seems like that the picture here
fits quite
nicely the definition of the hormone of
course
this was a very high risk idea because
hormones are considered to be mainly
belong to two categories being proteins
or
lipids nobody has ever thought of
hormones as being nucleic acids but
we decided to move on with this
hypothesis because it seemed quite
possible based on the premises
so uh in 2012 uh we published a paper
uh in which we started by uh screening
which micrornas were included as a cargo
of
extracellular vesicles releases released
by
non-small cell lung cancer cell lines
and as you see in the
tunnel a you here we have several dots
each of them representing a microrna
detected
with the nanostring technology as cargo
of microrna derived from
these cancer cell lines and then the red
bar that you see
actually represents the statistical
threshold so that whatever is underneath
is considered
noise so it's not necessarily really
there
but so basically this killed a lot of
our candidates but
we still had nine candidates that were
expressed above the threshold
and then we decided to validate these
list of nine candidates
within another technique which was the
quantitative real-time pcr
which you see listed in v here
and we ended up showing that indeed um
there were like in particular mere 21
and mere 29a
which were highly expressed in the lung
cancer cell line
compared to a cell line which was used
as a control 293 cells that as you know
are not
lung cells and are not even cancer cells
so we had at this point two candidates
mere 21 and 29
a that were very highly represented as
cargo of
vesicles released by non-small cell lung
cancer cell lines
but then the problem was okay so if
these hormones
if this microwave work as hormones first
off how do they work
and what is the destination cell so we
decided to
look at different proteins that are
known
to bind to single stranded rna which are
about 19 to 24 nucleotides in size
and actually they were two excellent
candidates and they belong to the family
of toll-like receptor family a family in
particular two like receptors seven
and eight that are known to bind to
single stranded rna
of viral origin so exogenous to the cell
that's their main
function to defend cells from infections
from exogenous rnas
but we thought they perhaps they could
be also
mere receptors so receptors of microrna
and transfer for instance from a cancer
cell
to a recipient cell so we started a
series of
experiments of colocalization that are
listed here so first off
we um focused on the top three
the top two candidates we we obtained
from the previous screening so mere 21
and 29
a we use the mere 16 because it was
expressed
equally in lung cancer cells and in
293 cells and so we use the lyso tracker
to label
the endosomal compartment where the like
receptors seven and eight are located
inside the cytoplasma cells
we uh labeled the tone-like receptor aid
itself
with green gfp and we created artificial
exosomes containing
the micrornas of interest labeled in red
and when we did the merging images when
you see
yellow it means colocalization so we
observe that all three
micrornas are able to enter the
recipient cell
from the artificial exosomes and
localized
in the endosomal compartment where the
tool like is located
of course this doesn't mean that the
mirror interacts with the receptor for
that
we had to perform immunoprecipitations
that you see in the
bar in the upper right side so here we
precipitated the um proteins of the
torilike receptor
and we observed an enrichment for mere
21 and 29a but not so much
for amir 16 whereas below
you see that we pull down the micro rna
and you
obtain like receptor eight only with
mere
29a and mere 21 but not with mere 16
or total which is the empty vesicle that
we use the plus or the other controls
and then the images you see underneath
they show that the main producer of
these
is this micrornas in this case is mere
29a
represented here is actually the cancer
cell not
the normal lung tissue counterpart
so we so we perform a series of the
colocalization experiments
uh inside hybridization and at the end
of the day we were able to show that the
recipient cell
is the tumor-associated macrophage
especially at the so-called tumor
interface
so at the line of demarcation between
the cancerous tissue
and the normal tissue in the normal
tissue surrounding it
and so we were able to formulate this
model in which we see that the cancer
cell the non-small cell and cancer cell
is able to secrete
uh vesicles containing mere 21 and year
29a
that is updating if taken taken by
tumor-associated macrophages especially
the interface with the tumor
and here the um exosome or vesicles i
should say
a fuses with the endosomal compartment
where the tone like receptor ate in
human
or its counter part in mouse which is
the lr7
is able to bind literally physically
with the
microrna triggering the downstream
signaling of
the receptor which is an f cap beta
signaling
which induces the secretion of tnf and
interleukin-6
which promote promotes tumor growth and
the metastatic potential
in a later publication in 2015
um dr chala gundla who now at the time
was a postdoc in my lab now is an
assistant professor at the university of
nebraska
so he was able to show that the same
crosstalk is
important in neuroblastoma so in
pediatric
cancer and again neuroblastoma cells
like lung cancer cells previously are
able to secrete mere 21. and
interestingly we didn't see the
secretion of mere 29a from this cell
line
but this mir-21 then is a taken by the
tumor-associated macrophages where it
binds to
like receptor eight triggers an f kappa
beta
activation which um transactivates the
expression of mere 155 so another
microrna
normally very um a little expressed in
the cancer cell itself so the
upregulation of mere 155
in the macrophage makes it also
packed inside of the exosomes derived
from these macrophages and transfer back
to the cancer cell
where these microrna targets genes such
as turf1
which is an inhibitor of telomerase
activity which induces increased
telomerase activity and increased
resistance to cisplatin showing that
these uh
a barren crosstalk between cancer
cells and macrophages mediated by the
binding to a mere sector the other aid
is actually relevant also for the
mechanisms of drug
resistance now i'm shifting gears a
little bit and telling you about some
more recent studies that are being
performed have been performed and are
being performed in my lab
and so we focused on another important
uh cellular component of innate immunity
which are
the natural killer cells as you know
natural killer cells
are prime cells to destroy
virally infected cells as well as tumor
cells
however so and they responded to a
series of signals
exchanged between the cell
and the nk cell itself in particular
some signals are permissive so they
actually
allow the killing of the cell by the nk
cells
some other cells on other signals are
inhibitory so they
tell nk cells essentially do not kill me
and based on the combination of these
two
groups of signals you have an outcome
which is the fact that the nk
cell actually does kill or not
but to complicate things uh what happens
in the tumor micro environment
is that um it has been shown
quite clearly at this point that the
tumor microenvironment
of several type of cancers is literally
imbued so full enriched in tgf beta
and tgf beta is a profound inhibitor of
nk killing activity so one of the ways
for um cancer cells to
escape the killing by nk cells is indeed
to have
a micro environment which is
particularly rich of
tgf beta the idea here
uh the overarching hypothesis here of
this project is that
perhaps we can use exosomes
so particles derived from nk cells
instead of nk cell themselves to kill
cancer cells and why would we think of
that
for a series of reasons the first one is
that
one of the problems that you have every
time really you perform a cell therapy
so
nk cell therapy included is that you
have
one or one important side effect of the
injection of cells
as therapeutic seeing patients is that
you might have the so-called cytokine
storm
which is a situation in which there is
like an a strong secretion of cytokines
that can actually lead to
important side effects like a very
excruciating headache or very high fever
that ultimately might lead the
oncologist even to stop the treatment
because
the side effects are just unbearable and
so at this point
the therapy is not effective anymore
because you have to stop it because of
side effects
so the idea here is that perhaps with
the vesicles instead of the cells
themselves you might actually
be able to prevent this cytokine storm
issue
from happening the other possibilities
which is number two here
is that you know cancer cells especially
leukemic cells
tend to have nests so to hide um
in the so-called pharmacologic
sanctuaries so
one being the brain another one being
the testis
where there is like a brain blood
barrier or a test this blood barrier
that prevents therapeutics and actually
in particular
cell therapeutics to cross the barrier
and enter
that compartment where the cancer cell
is actually nesting
so and and it has been shown actually at
this point by several papers that
vesicles derived from different type of
cells
including nk cells seems to be able to
cross
quite easily these um barriers this
anatomical
barrier that um you know
cancer cells use to to hide
and so this way these vesicles as
therapeutics can actually
reach also these pharmacological
sanctuaries then of course
all the signaling uh that occurs between
cancer cells and nk cells so in
particular the inhibitory signaling
perhaps are not at stake are not
necessarily
involved in the killing mediated by
vesicles
if you use vesicles instead of this nk
cell as therapeutic so
based on all these uh ideas we decided
to
follow up on these um interesting
hypotheses
and first off you know to make sure that
we can even go this way we have to be
able to obtain
big quantities of exosomes derived from
nk
cells and this has been possible thank
you
thanks to this uh paper by denman and
all that has been
optimized in collaboration with dr bob
seeger and dr young at children's
hospital los angeles
um we were able to develop
these modified protocol in which we
start from peripheral blood mononuclear
cells
that are put in contact with engineered
k-562 cells
so that essentially after like two weeks
of co-culture you have
a population of more than 95 percent
pure nk cells from which you can isolate
the vesicles that are at this point
almost all derived from
nk cells that are activated and so then
we were able to define the properties of
these nk derived vesicles and defined
that they fulfilled a minimal
requirement
of isaac the international society to
call them exosomes so that's why we use
this term from now on
but of course the one million dollar
question is are these vesicles able
actually to kill cancer cells or not
so here you see in two different
neuroblastoma cell lines
uh that it progressing from the
left to the right you have progressively
increasing concentration of vesicles and
gateride vesicles
and these cells these cancer cells are
luciferous labels so
when they die when they are killed you
see a down regulation
in the signal because the cells are not
you know um
expressing luciferase anymore because
they're dying so you see that in both
cases at some point
we have we reach a concentration of
vesicles that are able to significantly
inhibit
the growth of these cells
or to kill the cells i should say and
interestingly while
in chla255 so you look at the green bars
here
there seems to be a plateau that is
reached after which even if you keep
going up with the concentration of
vesicles the cells do not keep
kill being killed more and more in the
chla 136 so in the purple bars you see
that there seems to be a progressively
increased dying
with the uh increased concentration of
vesicles
then we performed a series of functional
experiments these were performed by dr
nediani
and now he's directing an extracellular
vesicle core facility
at children's hospital los angeles which
i encourage you to check in on the
website if you need
excellent work characterizing your
vesicles at the time it was a postdoc in
my lab and he performed these
experiments
showing that especially not only
um vesicles are able to kill as well
as nk cells but what we observed
is that if you have an environment in
which you have
tgf data then and
nk cells are not killing anymore as we
expect
but nk derived exosomes keep killing
as if tgf beta wasn't present and so
this is a very important observation
because it tells us that
an advantage that honestly we didn't
even foresee when we were thinking of
using vesicles versus the cells
an advantage a further advantage of
using vesicles over the cells is
actually they can work
and they can kill cancer cells even in
presence of
a lot of tgf data which was that
cytokine that was
inhibiting the function of nk cells
and of course then um we also performed
this experiment in which we
um um silenced
the uh expression of drosha which is key
in the machinery of
um micrornas and we were able to
so basically we silenced russia in nk
cells so this point we impaired the
production of
microrna by nk cells we took the
exosome from these treated cells nk
cells and we put it on the top of chla
136 and checked for the killing
and as you can see if you silence russia
these vesicles from nk cells are not as
good as
in in killing as neurograms as if the
russia
was present so that tells us that
micrornas
are among the different components of
the cargo of these nk derived cells
are some important mediators of the
killing effect so what are the micrornas
contained in the um nk derived
exosomes we have a list here done in
collaboration with dr seeger schla
and among the different candidates we
were really interested in the one that
has been highlighted mere 186
the reason being because it is predicted
bioinformatically to target
some very important genes in
neuroblastoma
such as mick and that as you know is
that
driving oncogene in this disease and as
you know also as of now
it it is not a targetable gene because
pharmacologically it's impossible to
target mick and so using a micronate to
target it could be
an interesting um approach in addition
to that you see the tgf data receptor
one is a predicted target
as well as downstream mediators of the
tgf beta receptor pathways
so smart two and three and alk and
aurora kinase a which is also an and
stabilizer of mechan so by targeting
aurora kinase a you can
also indirectly target mechanics so for
all these reason
reasons we focused on mere 186 but first
i just want to show you this slide that
shows that with
a technique based on size exclusion
chromatography
we were able to um separate different
isolate different
fractions of extracellular vesicles and
you can observe that the marker cd81
and tsg101 of exosomes starts appearing
in fractions that would say between
11 and 14 which happens to be also where
you have
the highest amount of mere 186 which is
contained in the nk derived exosome and
an acceptable amount of contaminating
proteins
which come out later on in the
later fractions so using this method
we decided to proceed with our
experiment but first we wanted to see if
mere 186 actually targets the genome the
genes of interest and here you can see
that if you transfect
neuroblastoma cell lines to different
lines with mere 186 you have down
regulation of mcn aurora kinase a
and we performed also um lucifer as
reporter assays
showing that indeed mere 186 targets
directly
mick and and aurora kinase a and this
effect is
exactly in the predicted binding site
because if you mutagenize these size or
you delete it
then the luciferase activity is not
reduced anymore
but then we observe also that the mir is
targeting the tgf data signaling um
by targeting smart2 and smart three uh
luciferase was not
uh significant for zlatwe so that means
that the mirror is not directly
targeting
these two genes but indirectly we don't
know exactly what is the mediator of
this silencing
but we know also that in addition to tgs
beta r1 mir186 also targets dgf beta r2
so both receptors
and this is quite profound because as i
told you tgf beta is an immunosuppressor
because it interacts with the tgf
data pathway and very important
is that the graph that you should see in
the bottom
left side because here we use the
reporter
system to show activation of the tgf
beta pathway
and here we show that even in presence
of the agonists of tgf beta
the pathway is completely silenced
if mere 186 is expressed so
that tells you that mere 186 effect on
the pathway is so profound
that it's its presence is able to block
the activation of the pathway
even in presence of the agonist of tgs
data itself
um we performed the um growth curves for
the neuroblastoma cell lines in presence
of mere 186
showing that their growth is reduced and
also in a scratch
wound healing assay we observe that the
presence of mir186 reduces the migration
of neuroblastoma cells and reduces also
the migration
in presence of a chemo attract them
through a trans well
migration assays so all of these
experiments essentially are in agreement
with the tumor-suppressive role of mere
186
then we were able dr naviani was able to
generate
anionic lipopolyplex nanoparticles
containing mere 186
and they can be actually um coated with
different type of antibodies
um and according to the type of
antibodies that you
coat them with you can direct them in
their microrna content with to one cell
or another of the tumor micro
environment
here is just to show that the if you
transfect
nk cells with these nanoparticles
containing mere 186
in particular if you coat them with the
antibody against the cd56 which is the
market for mk cells you're able to
deliver more efficiently this mere in nk
cells and you can find it also in the
exosomes derived from nk
cells and likewise if you silence near
186 with an anti
near 186 um log nucleic acid
antisense uh we perform these uh
internal b you see the dow regulation of
the relevant genes tgf beta receptor one
and two in
nk cells so um we have here a situation
where the same microrna can be
beneficial both if you transfer it to
the cancer cells because of its effect
on mick and relevant oncogenes
but also on the mk cells themselves
because by
silencing tgf beta receptor expression
and the downstream pathway
you can silence the inhibitory effect of
tgf data on the nk
function and then we perform the in vivo
experiment
showing that in orthotropic models of
neuroblastoma so here we injected
neuroblastoma cells in the perirenal
capsule of these
mice where neuroblastoma develops and
these
cells are lucifer is expressing so you
can actually follow the growth of the
tumor in the
individual four groups of animals in the
upper side you see the animals treated
with
injection of the nanoparticles as they
showed you before
containing scramble so nothing in them
and coated with an a specific igg
antibody
and you see that the tumors keep growing
whereas
in the second group you have a
nanoparticle containing near 186 and
coated with
an a specific antibody in the third
group from the top you see the
nanoparticle containing scramble encoded
with empty gd2 antibody gd2 is a
specific
surface marker for neuroblastoma and
then the fourth group
so the bottom row of mice which is the
actual experimental group
here you have animals treated with
nanoparticles containing near 186
encoded with anti-gd2 antibody
so clearly because probably the
nanoparticle is more effective in
delivering the mir to the cancer cells
you see that the tumors grow much much
less and the survival is
increased so overall um i will summarize
these uh um findings by saying that
extracellular vesicles as you
i hope you have been convinced by now
can be classified in different subtypes
and exosomes are a subtype of evs
uh if these are involved in several
aspects of cancer biology as
the literature i i briefly mentioned
showed you
uh evrna's shape the rna shapes the
biology of the tumor microenvironment in
particular microrna can affect this
biology
by working through the traditional
mechanisms and alternative mechanisms
including the
binding to a receptor and activation of
its downstream signaling
tlr8 represents the first form and as of
now the only one i'm aware of
of mere receptors a receptor for
microrna it is important for cancer
growth dissemination resistant to
therapy
mere 186 in nk's derived exosome
as an anti-tumor effect likely working
by targeting mcn or a kinase a and
blocking the tgf data receptor and
downstream signaling pathway and
antibody
coated nanoparticles can specifically
deliver microrna or antimicronic cargo
to target cells
and i would like to conclude by
acknowledging um
several people in my my previous lab at
the children's hospital los angeles the
doctor nadiani
is in the upper picture the second one
from the left
who performed several experiments i
showed you
and people in my uh
more recently established lab at the
university of hawaii cancer center
in the bottom picture and of course the
funding agencies that supported these
studies both federal agencies
and private foundation and of course the
patients and their families for
providing the samples for these studies
and i thank you so much for your
attention i will
wait for your questions that you might
have and i will
try to answer them as soon as possible
thank you so much
okay awesome job well we are all set so
pretty much from here i'll just do some
quick editing on the front and back end
since there was no
interruptions during your presentation
and then we'll have it ready for the
event
next week sounds great well thank you so
much for
your support that was a lot of fun yeah
definitely and thank you so much for
taking the time to present we appreciate
it thank you very much
already bye-bye bye-bye